yo creo que el principal temor es
básicamente que a los niños usualmente
la enfermedad tiende a ser bastante leve
en comparación como adolescentes y
adultos y ellos se preguntan por que
vacunarlos si realmente la enfermedad es
bastante leve no y el mensaje
básicamente es la enfermedad es leve en
la mayoría de los casos pero siempre hay
casos en que no es no es leve y hemos
tenido una buena cantidad de niños
hospitalizados
hemos tenido muerte por el niño por kobe
y hemos tenido este síndrome
inflamatorio multisistémico que nadie
sabe a quién le va a dar en la población
pediátrica que precisamente se ve en la
edad escolar entre 5 y 11 años de edad y
que uno no puede predecir a quién le da
o a quien no le da no entonces eso es un
argumento básicamente para para
vacunarnos además si las vacunas han
demostrado seguridad en niños y los
datos de la cbs por ejemplo 9 niños 9
millones de niños vacunados ya dos
millones con dos dosis y realmente los
eventos el perfil de seguridad es
espectacular de las vacunas al menos de
la infancia entonces no hay razón
realmente a negarse a la vacunación de
hecho nosotros en pediatría hemos
vacunado contra la varicela contra
hepatitis contra el rotavirus que son
enfermedades incluso más benignas que el
kobe de la población infantil